it's hard not to notice even when you
can't bear to look I'm scared to death
because I depend on that extra money to
pay for my car and to pay for groceries
and things like that
gas prices once again on the rise a cash
crunch for commuters that really
stretches the family budget when I first
started gas was only two dollars 20
cents a gallon now it's up to almost $3
a gallon depending where you shop that
makes a big difference the while the
usual talk of the approaching summer
driving season being the reason for the
rise is out there experts say there's
actually much more at work here than
just the calendar concerns about the
Iran nuclear deal pull out for one which
some speculate could trim global
supplies consider oils plunge from over
$100 a barrel in 2014 to just below $30
a barrel in early 2016 and accordingly
prices fell but since then they had been
on the rise with West Texas crude the US
benchmark now topping 71 dollars a
barrel that's up 14% since the beginning
of the year and that means more pain at
the pump with today's national price per
gallon averaging 284 that's up 19 cents
over last month and 51 cents higher than
this time last year experts say that's
in part because Wall Street traders
anticipated the president's decision to
pull out of the Iran deal the market was
prepared for the u.s. to pull out it was
a campaign promise he's been known to do
whatever he can in his power whether
good or bad for the present situation to
keep his campaign promises the president
has also promised to retaliate against
those who unfairly manipulate the price
of oil tweeting just last month
looks like OPEC is at it again oil
prices are artificially very high no
good and will not be accepted read
experts argue this frankly not much the
president can do about the problem short
of tapping the nation's strategic
reserves and that's a move they say
would only give us temporary relief at
the pump and quite frankly it would also
be quite unprecedented